Oh, you can have the last strawberry.
Oh thank you!
OVER MY DEAD BODY...
(smacking and nyaming noises)
First, I would still eat that.
And two, why do people even say
(slowed) "Over my dead body"?
Whenever someone says that, it's like,
"Yeah dude, obviously I'm not gonna kill you over whatever we're talking about."
But if I was..
are you REALLY willing to die for this?
Are you really..
willing..
to die?
You'll get that strawberry over my dead body.
(dramatic music)
Wanna duel?
(lightning strikes)
(groans)
Well that was easy.
I mean, unless it's booby trapped.
(beeping)
(lasers screech)
God dammit.
(screeching continues)
I was wondering where the phrase
"over my dead body" even came from,
so I asked my best friend,
the internet.
"Though not much is known about its origins,
scholars do know that it was used during the 1800s,
as a common hyperbolic expression often used in jest."
They joked in the 1800s?
"What was a typical joke for the 1800s?"
(old fashioned music)
Mother,
it strikes me that you are VERY LAZY just now.
(gasp)
How dare you say so!
Why?
Don't you see I'm making bread?
True,
but that is neither more nor less than LOAFING!
VO: The juvenile prankster got no
hotcakes several days thereafter.
The mother is slowly recovering.
That was pretty good.
Yeah, for 200 years old, that's not that bad.
I'm sure that was like comedy gold back in the day.
This whole video is basically just me saying,
"I don't like the phrase 'over my dead body'."
Because it insinuates a challenge.
And when you challenge me,
challenge accepted.
Most thanks to Audible.com for
sponsoring today's video.
Audible is the leading provider of audiobooks,
with more than 250,000 titles to choose from,
across of all different types of literature.
I love listening to audiobooks
when I'm annoying Mummy.
Right now, I'm listening to
To All The Boys I've Loved Before,
because girls are confusing creatures.
Audible is offering a free 30 day trial,
to give you a chance to try out their service.
Go to audible.com/anna to download a free title,
and start listening today.
Audible.com/anna.